vous les avez reconnus c'est qui au
bonjour messieurs bonjour luis enrique
benoît nicolas florian et jocelyn alors
on est chez vous ici à
verneuil-sur-seine vous allez revenir
pour un grand concert qui sera organisée
le 25 juin prochain au parc du château
notre dame les oiseaux alors qu'est ce
que ça vous fait messieurs benoît
peut-être ben c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion c'est vrai que on en parlait
en fait
ça fait longtemps qu'on parle de cette
idée et
le fait que ça se réalise enfin
en plus ça se réalise à un moment où
nous nous on a on a repris la tournée
après deux ans de frustration que ce
soit pour le public ou pour nous de ne
pas avoir pu jouer donc ça fait
aussi 20 ans que le groupe existe donc à
tout ça est assez symbolique en fait et
et ouais je sais par découvrir l'endroit
parce que même si on a de la famille sûr
dans les environs dont convient dans la
région mais attendez sens de la famille
dans quoi un drive in ouais mais assez
vrai que moi j'ai pas mis les pieds dans
l'enceinte de l'établissement depuis
plus de vingt ans donc forcément c'est
nouveau et ça fait quoi justement à
venir ici basse et c'est plein de
souvenirs en forcément qui remonte à la
surface on sait on sait tous rencontrés
avec flo plutôt dans le coin là bas des
maternelles avec ben juste à côté donc
c'est vrai que tout ça revient et c'est
vrai qu'en plus mais on n'était pas
faire moi je sais que j'étais pas sûr
que l'école puisse organiser un concert
de cette taille là dans l'enceinte de
l'établissement parce que bon c'est
quand même beaucoup de beaucoup de monde
donc ça c'est vraiment super que qu'ils
aient pu organiser ça donc c'était en
1994 c'est bien ça que vous êtes trop
près on s'est rencontré
ouais avec flo on s'est rencontré en
très tôt à aller à kwenge de vers 12 13
ans donc en 92
ouais à peu près et on sait mais on
était aussi à maternelle ici donc nico
était dans la même classe que mon grand
frère déjà
quatre ans
quatre hommes ou que les gens n'avaient
pas commencé à faire un groupe encore et
ouais on sait qu'on est rentré vers 13
devait avoir 12 13 ans et le rock
c'était l'évidence pour vous tout de
suite c'est ce qu'on écoute à l'époque
je pense que c'est ça qui nous a réuni
aussi on avait vraiment disant qu ans
tous les deux on apprenait wire ou qu'il
fallait mais les trucs de
genre les guns ce nirvana red hot chili
peppers comme ça de l'époque 2003 où
vous êtes produit pour la première fois
ici dans les yvelines pour un concert au
complexe sportif françois pons de
verneuil est-ce que vous en souvenez ou
pas du tout voici parce que c'est quand
même ça fait partie des tout premiers
concerts donc on s'en souvient il était
comment ce concert justement là qu'on
avait approché justement l'idée de
revenir jouer dans le coin mais sans
jamais vraiment imaginer qu'on pourrait
se mettre dans le parquet ait joué là où
je faisais du foot
vite en quoi je souffre 100 personnes
qui seront denses et ce à quoi le palais
en plus j'avais imaginé t on pourrait
mettre la scène ici et tout ça jamais
faisable pour des raisons de sécurité
tout ça comme nico mais là si ça va se
faire un peu fou est ce qu'on réalisé ou
pas du tout
depuis demain déjà depuis qu'on est
arrivé dans la rue là juste avant là ça
commence à réaliser un peu plus
kwajalein a revu des têtes de profs
qu'on n'avait pas vu j'avais pas s'il y
aurait des profs qu'on comprend qu'on
avait eu ou pas quoi il ya eu des bonnes
surprises et zoom donc c'est si je
commence à réaliser un peu est ce que ça
vous met un peu la pression justement ce
concert vu que c'est dans un lieu où
vous connaissez a particulièrement bien
ça aurait été un premier concert de
tourner je pense qu'on aurait carrément
la pression mais là là où tous les shows
qu'on a fait pour l'instant sont hyper
bien passé donc on est assez assez
serein je pense qu'au contraire ça va
être ça va être quelque chose en plus
sûres ça va être
je pense que le show il est rodé donc ça
nous y'a pas de problème mais
mais on va nous vivre une émotion
particulière évidemment par rapport aux
autres autre date donc ouais on a super
hot si vous allez faire quelque chose de
particulier ou pas pour cette date je
sais parce qu'alice surprise ou est-ce
qu'il faut pas trop en parler
bien évidemment il ya des surprises je
t'avoue qu'on n'en a pas encore discuté
encore hélas tu viens de me faire
réaliser que effectivement c'est bien
c'est peut-être une bonne chose merci à
vous et bon concert le 25 juin prochain
ce sera ici là où tout a commencé à
verneuil sur seine le concert commencera
à 21h